welcome back to another episode of not
too deep with me your host grace and
Helbig the first today we have zeyneb
Johnson on the podcast she is an
absolutely wonderful human being she's a
straight-up comedian she is cool as heck
at one time her mom stood up in the
middle of a movie theater at creed 2 and
thought that she was actually at the
boxing match get ready for this very
fun-filled and also I think really like
thoughtful sweet conversation episode of
not too deep this episode of not too
deep is brought to you by our good
buddies at Squarespace turn your great
idea into a reality with Squarespace
they make it easier than ever to launch
your passion project whether you are
showcasing your work or selling products
of any kind with beautiful templates and
the ability to customize just about
anything you can easily make a beautiful
website all on your own but if you do
get stuck Squarespace is 24/7
award-winning customer support is there
to help head squarespace.com such grace
pray free trial and when you are ready
to launch use the offer code grace Jerry
C e to save 10% off your first purchase
of a website or domain Xena thank you so
much for being here this is so fun you
were literally less than 24 hours off of
a plane from Cancun so thank you because
my pleasure I would not be here if I
were you I appreciate your presence what
were you in Cancun for I was vacationing
a friend of my event one of my oldest
friends it was her birthday on his fun
Sunday I believe you and the sixth
whatever day was the sixth and she
wanted to go and normally she takes time
off work and comes to visit me out here
okay and she was like will you be around
and I was like yeah I think I'll be in
LA and she was like I'm gonna come for
my birthday and I was like you sure you
want to come here like we'll just eat
food that we know we already like you
have to sit through my comedy are you
sure that's what you want and it's cold
I'm wearing a wool coat yes is last
thing I'm like it's cold here she was
like okay let me I mean China booked
Mexico
let's reconsider yeah maybe go a little
warmer you've been working your ass off
the last couple years but it feels like
I've been stalking you no offence on
every form of social media the last like
48 hours and you are the coolest human
being to me I love everything you're
doing and I love everything and no
offense I'm gonna say it now 2019 is
your year I'm so excited for you I
literally cannot wait a year from now to
see what's happening because I feel like
right now you're like the freshest voice
coolest human that's happening right now
thank you so much I hope this time next
year we're not sitting here disappointed
even like dm2 asked to come no but
that's why I'm like you probably don't
take a break so going to Cancun must
have felt a little strange I think
because I traveled so much as a comedian
right you always feel like you're going
somewhere but then you realize like oh
wow I'm always working like yes it's not
even when you go to seemingly nice
places it's like my first time how was
Australia it's like I mean it was great
but it's like I'm exhausted yeah you
know because I was because you did the
Melbourne comedy Yeah right
how what was that the first time that
you did that first time how was it for
you it was great yeah great for me yeah
I would I would like to go back it was
what do you notice in the
differentiation between like audiences
states versus like a place like
Australia do you notice any difference
Australia is really white yeah
and so but what I mean is a lot of
audiences here they can't like I can
find myself
oftentimes in front of a very white
audience in the United States soo yeah
but I think just internationally you
always have to it's a reference thing
you have to try not to be regional
because they just don't understand it
but other than that it's like I think
because they were because they're so
white I was like a breath of fresh air
Michelle
for like two whole weeks it was amazing
okay where's your favorite place to
perform in the States probably New York
yeah yeah yeah but I started comedy in
LA and I and I do really enjoy doing
comedy in LA I would say New York
Portland Oh No
New York and probably San Francisco in a
Liana like the same bye okay
yeah like San Francisco is cool enough
and right before like the the Portland
and the Seattle's that get so PC it's
like there's no laughter it's like yeah
I was not trying to make a [ __ ] point
can I curse you can absolutely why this
is not a TED talk what do you use it why
are you assigning that way well that's
so interesting you hear I always have
mixed vibes in San Francisco it's very
fun and very laid-back but it's also
like too cool yeah I mean that I feel
like I'm absorbed as a dork there and
and they know it and I know it and so
it's just a mutual experience but can't
wait to go this weekend okay you've a
degree in mathematics is this true math
and education yes and since you like
double you were a teacher at first yeah
okay so what talk me through the
progression of going from teacher to
where you are now
it was just not even that deep I was in
college I didn't really know what I
wanted to do I had always been good at
math and so I just naturally went and
and I really didn't want to teach yeah I
wanted to teach high school I ended up
teaching really elementary and middle
school but I wanted to teach high school
and with high school you have to choose
a subject yes you have subjects and I
was just good at math you know for a
good while I mean my last year the math
got pretty advanced and I was like oh
this isn't fun anymore
you know but I was already committed
and I was one of those B I think I was
like my mom my parents went to college
but never finished and I so if nothing
else in my mind it was like I gotta
finish yeah who cares what I do with
this after at least I finish and then I
started my student teaching and my
teacher that was like that lead teacher
for me was asked I believe I'm
remembering this correctly was asked to
contribute to the new math textbooks for
the following year and so that pulled
him out the classroom and so I just
wasn't naturally like I had got you know
my student teaching was done I graduated
I had passed my and it was like Oh a
natural progression to like you know
become like the full-time teacher yeah
but the it was so short because the the
kids were great yeah I was standing in
the class one day and I just had an
epiphany I was like I'm just not here
for this really yeah there was nothing
specific it was just a random moment
yeah yeah I was just and I mean they
were great like this this school was
like a charter school so their parents
were very much involved yeah the kids on
a whole I mean they have so there were
certain kids of course that I like to
bet more than I sure you know but I mean
I wish more people would say hey I
talked about how I like some of my
nieces and nephews over the other well I
never say and I my siblings are all
trying to guess like well whose kids are
don't worry about you know but I mean
little people kids they have personality
you know so I get to choose whose
personality I that's not gonna dictate
your test score right right but it will
dictate how I feel about you and how I
talk about cheats and my friends when I
leave you but I also feel like that is
like unofficial training for stand-up I
mean you just stand in front of a room
of people that are judging you like
crazy and some of them don't want to be
there and they don't know why they're
there
so I feel like that is kind of helpful
for what you're doing now I appreciate
that
I don't agree maybe they're the worst
audience and yeah I give a [ __ ] about
with some little kids that what I could
care so when I first moved to LA when I
first was a lady when I first moved to
LA I still like I needed to make money
and so I start at first I got certified
to teach here okay man to do substitute
teaching here it's like the places where
they had a lot of availability were like
in camps I didn't know that meant Jail
and so I would just go to these places
and you're like oh I'm teaching like
young like juvenile inmates yeah like
that and that was like there were three
of those and I was like oh well I took
the wrong you know like the wrong thing
yeah so I met this woman I can't
remember how when she did this um like
nonprofit program they brought the arts
back into the school is like after LAUSD
took out arts physical education you
know and so she had this program and so
I started teaching seventh graders like
sort of like improv and theater yeah I
mean I was not qualified to teach and I
would try to get them to understand I
only say middle I'm saying seventh
graders because they were so they're
them they would be the ones that you
would be worried about because they have
all these thoughts and thoughts they're
very self-conscious they're very catty
both the boys and the good vibe rating
systems insecurities yes and something
is happening in their lives and they had
just have no control over it and they're
trying to navigate it the best way
possible and you you maybe help you
you're just like a speed bump you're
just an interfering yeah and their
growth you know and I would try to get
them to understand in any situation like
this is such a small part of your life I
see your bigger picture trust me
yeah this is this is miniscule yeah yeah
you know compared to like what life will
dilemmas that you'll get in life so just
please
no did you ever have a specific student
say anything to you that resonated that
you kept with you no no follow-up
questions got it I will say this there's
this little girl in my class in a suit
there was these two kids they were twins
and I like the brother I like he needed
he like he's a kid they would say oh he
has a DD or ADHD but I'm like nah he
just needs more attention and he needs
to always be doing some occupy right but
then his sister was a mean girl oh no
she was a mean girl no I couldn't say it
yeah I used to look at the other girls
like just trust me this is her last year
I couldn't say it I don't have to but I
used to have these these thoughts about
her like I don't even know who makes and
you can't figure it out yeah and you
just can't even say because you know
that's like personal that's not your
place but then I saw her and her brother
in their parents at like a street fair
in LA and the school they call you by
your first name showed me were like
saying it oh my god that's my teacher
that's my teacher and I turned around
like oh I definitely don't want to see
you all of the parents looked at me like
oh this is who you guys have been talk
like like happy to see me and I'm like
oh well I guess I'm making a difference
you know yeah yeah like even with my
nephew who I always say I don't like
he's like my one nephew I might God do
not mess with him we always ask him
who's like your favorite aunt or uncle
he always says me and like why I'm sad
because you're the one who's amazing
tension from you're the one who's like
giving it to him and so he wants it now
don't give him what they want and then
the one it more
you're one of 13 yes siblings don't take
any credit for that though that's my mom
that's so insane to me and I've been
watching so many of your stand-up bits
we are so funny I love that you're a
whole bit about statistically two and a
half of you should be gay yeah out of 13
and you guys don't know who it is yet
do your siblings ever watch your standup
have they ever commented are there any
like unsafe things that you can't talk
about so far there has not been anything
off limits okay but because I think
whenever I talk about them I still I
think my intent is always with love yeah
I think they're very pressing it's all
about like what wins my joke knows about
me yeah like my that date Journal joke
yeah I did my brother was at the Seth
Meyers taking will his hair secure
brother oh so we're in the car riding to
30 rock and I was like so just FYI I'm
doing a joke this about you and he says
is it when you thought I was getting you
read my journal
[Laughter]
taping like the entire crew everybody
was like who's the cuz two of my
brothers are there I was like who's the
brother who's the brother and then they
pointed out he was like I'm the brother
and they're like how do you feel about
that he was like I have many journals
that's why I love him he's so like his
in on the joke and he's just so he's
unfazed
ya know it's like you if somebody he's
he's not gay but if somebody called him
gay he'd just be like think like thank
you yeah and I just love there's certain
qualities about him and I just wish that
I know so sweet and that's so great that
they could be there for that yeah was
that your first late night JP yes okay
and that was like four months ago right
by the time this comes out maybe like a
half a year ago yeah I think it was in
November how was that for you it was a
lot of fun yeah it was a lot of fun and
I'm so happy I was um
my set was running long like I kept
working it out I never know I've had
friends do it I don't do stand-up so I
don't know how that works in terms of
like you do a full set they edit it down
I don't know no they don't edit it not
for your late-night set because it's
just posed to be like five minutes timed
out perfectly yeah yeah and I mean if
you go like five oh five or if you go
like four thirty it's like fine but
mine's coming in I was running it like
every night like multiple night multiple
times at The Improv it will come in like
seven something like seven minutes like
you know yeah and I don't even think
like now the TV things that I have taped
is with standup
you never even want to give them too
much to edit because then you are
relying on the editor to choose what
stays not just to choose what stays but
to have your same comedic Sensibility to
you know like you're putting a lot of
power on a stranger yeah it's like it's
like taking like a Picasso yeah so when
saying crop this however you want like
take out whatever corner that actually
may be the best and most interesting
part of the art yeah exactly like I gave
you do you know a 12 by 8 yeah you know
you make it into a four by yeah you know
so but it was it was it was fun to do
you seemed unfazed if that was your
first time doing it was my first time
zone in this comedian told me he had
done Conan and I was like is there any
advice I was getting a lot of advice
from different people and everybody had
different advice but his was the one
that helped me most he was like just
have fun he said and bring people which
is how my brothers got there he's like
bring people that can be in a green room
that make you feel good and like will
keep your mind off of it he said because
what you have to understand about
late-night is you're going to take
you're gonna go last on the show he said
and it's an hour full of written jokes
and you're the only one that's not the
celebrity so it's like Seth or whoever
the host is is doing written jokes by
professional but you know part of the
system yeah and then those jokes are
written a certain way and then
celebrities are going to come on and so
the studio audience is like that's a
celebrity everything they say is funny
or heartfelt or whatever
you know and now your last and they
don't know you and they're tired yes and
so you know just make sure that you have
that energy before so that you could
take it out there and just have a good
time and I mean it was the best that's
okay I mean it worked because the whole
set is great you can find on youtube
take we're going to take a break so
while we take a break go look up or set
on YouTube it's very very fun and we'll
be right back with zeyneb johnson on not
your deep this episode is brought to you
by Squarespace
turn your dream into a reality with
Squarespace they make it easier than
ever to launch your passion project
whether it's looking to start a new
business showcase your work published
content sell products or more
Squarespace is the tool for you they
have beautiful templates created by
world-class designers and the ability to
customize just about anything with a few
clicks you can easily make a beautiful
website all on your own they also have a
powerful ecommerce functionality which
lets you sell anything online and
analytics that help you grow in real
time everything is optimized for mobile
right out of the box and there's nothing
to patch or upgrade ever buying domains
is simple and you'll get the help you
need with Squarespace is 24/7
award-winning customer support they
empower millions of people from
designers to lawyers artists to gamers
even restaurants and gyms to turn great
ideas into something real head to
squarespace.com slash Grace for a free
trial and when you are ready to launch
use the offer code grace grac e to save
10% off your first purchase of a website
or domain that squarespace.com slash
grace offer code grace we're bad
I loved love loved your most recent
Instagram post I'm sorry yeah it was a
very sincere post and I appreciated it a
lot and I wonder where you'll and being
an extremely funny person on like cuz I
struggle with going back and forth I'm
like how sincere should I be online will
it be taken seriously if I am sincere
versus like should I make a dumb quip
about whatever the [ __ ] I'm posting
where I really really respected and
loved the post that you do but where do
you land on that are you still kind of
figuring that out for yourself or do you
feel like you're just gonna do whatever
you want when you feel like it and
unabashedly put it out there I am gonna
try myself too I'm gonna try my best to
be just more more authentic yeah and I
come off like a really authentic person
even authentic for me to say I come off
like a really but it felt like a
vulnerable post and that's what I like
the most about it is I think that it's a
big issue for me and sure and I really
meant what I said because I get inspired
by so many you know many people how many
women I follow online who showed their
scars daily or a show that they're
missing a limb or that they beat cancer
or did they and I'm just like she's just
the best then I look at myself and I'm
like I'm not representing myself the way
that these women you know and then I'm
like like I could totally like contrived
this beached photo [ __ ] sure and I could
crop it in a way for you to see all my
lady parts and for everybody to get that
yes it'll get the same amount of likes
this you're something different like oh
you sexy oh can I marry you oh can you
doubt it yeah and it's like for me it's
really empty because it's like that you
know like they don't know anything about
me right they don't they don't know
they're liking this version of me that I
yeah isn't it to them that's not
actually me yeah and it's like I went to
Cancun for vacation but every moment I
had to decide to reveal myself for
strangers which is not relaxing at all
like my friend whose birthday it was
just wanted to play volleyball and my
decision wasn't like do I feel like
playing volleyball or not my decision
was do I feel like people staring at me
and do what I'm saying like that's what
I had to decide and
I was just like it so that's like I'm
here to have fun with her on her
birthday that so you know like I'm a
fucked-up decision to have to make and
then I just it's just like but that's
very relatable to a lot of people I
think which is what I related to it now
so it's just like this is so cool that
you can be so funny so confident and
then also be this version of yourself
too and I loved it so much and I think I
which I really need to work on and that
was the reason why I made it public I
posted them before yeah I post them on
my stories like these cars is getting
their son you know whatever but I don't
know I just feel like there's just it's
just necessary I feel like social media
is great but it also sucks and we're not
like true representations of ourselves
yeah we're a curated version of
ourselves everyone and we can showcase
as much toxicity on earth or we can
showcase as much of like look how
awesome seemingly my life and I am and
I'm the most confident person in the
world but those real posts I think have
inherently more value than any like
beauty glamour shoot that you would do
in a bikini on a beach anywhere yeah I
got a lot of like dams with people
sharing like sending me pictures yeah I
know of either them were their children
who their concerns like whoa as she
approaches womanhood with this like scar
or whatever how will it and I don't know
if you noticed like I don't I don't
really get sappy in my in my post oh
that's why it lied to me so much it's
like I'm not trying to appeal to you
guys I'm just trying to be a little bit
more honest with myself just trying to
really but but by you being yourself has
infinite resonation with other people
that want to find someone like you to
look up to them they're like I want to
be as authentic as she's being right now
that's why I was like this is very cool
a couple of other people who like I
think that I'm hilarious they were like
wait I just read the last part you said
when you get exceptionally funny you're
already exceptionally funny and it's
like I also get exhausted in comments so
I'm like I think too responding and I
say don't feel like it because if I go
down this rabbit hole with you guys
talking all day and I can't do it the
reason why I said exceptionally funny is
because it it - two reasons one when I
first started comedy maybe like a year
and a half in one of my brothers I don't
know if you ever seen my joke my trash
joke or my brother says the [ __ ] is
trash anyway no he was at my house one
day and I got out the shower and he was
like oh those are your legs and honks
like yeah and he was like no I mean I
knew but I kind of forgot cuz I don't
see you often I don't see you on you
know undress often and I was like yeah
and I didn't really get self-conscious
but then right when it got a little bit
like the awkward silence yeah he was
just like if I wasn't your brother
I let you know it just it was it was so
funny to me
right it's like I just died like I
remember one appreciate like it was his
it was like the hood version of a hug
and then it was just like and then I
just felt like it he was he's so funny
and I had a show that night and I went
onstage and I'd say exactly what I just
said to you and I thought it would get
that reaction but everybody in the
audience was like oh and I was like no
no it's funny we're good in the moment I
was thinking like is it because I'm not
showing it so they can't they can't
visualize it and so me like I don't I
couldn't I can I didn't understand where
the where the humor failed yeah you're
nothing like the triumph yeah failed in
then when I got off stage the woman who
booked me for the show was like what was
that and I was like I mean like I know
as well as I hoped and this is that you
know you're gonna happen you got your
five minutes that you know works
whatever whatever and she was like when
I booked you on the show
do the set that I know whoa yeah and I
knew like like I knew I knew two things
after that I knew I was never doing her
show and I knew like okay I'm not funny
enough to tell this to make this funny
yet Oh interest and so it's kind of like
a goal of mine like no I know that I am
supremely funny yeah when I have
strangers laughing at this that's you
know like that's my mark yeah yeah yeah
I fully get that and I've never thought
about it that way before that's so
that's what I'm in a pose so anybody
that's like no girl you so funny is like
yes I think it's a great kind of vision
board for yourself for this year to be
like this is what I'm going to do more
than like I'm looking for sympathy right
now that's what I took the former rather
than the latter from that and I was very
cool speaking New Year's resolutions you
wanted to take up cooking more yay okay
tell me about this I can't cook okay
what I love to eat and I recently
watched Julie and Julia or something
like that oh and not that the movie was
so touching but every time they show it
what she was cooking I was like oh and
it's like wanted to open and she thought
almost posted online I probably still
will it's like Meryl Streep tastes like
they come with this pan full of butter
fish it's like simmering and I don't
even really like fish like that and NHS
it slides off the bone and I'm just I'm
looking at it like and I'm like I'm
watching on Netflix and I'm like oh my
god like we're who what Oh like I want
that right now and then Meryl Streep
taste it and she's just having this
whole like and her husband
and taste it and then they don't even
have words she's like oh it's like she
doesn't even and I'm like what that I
want that why have you ever watched Food
Network I feel like you would have a
really great time that all day like
seeing fish being plated it was like and
I just think you know what I was like oh
I hope that fish wasn't cold like but
when she tasted it she didn't have to
pretend that I hope that that was a true
moment I spent so many so much money
eating out I'm gonna learn to cook this
year today I was actually deciding
mm-hmm
cuz I went my grocery shopping and it
had nowhere to start
I'm like spice it like I don't need a
spice until yeah until some a recipe
calls for spice you know like I don't
just have garlic sitting around my
everybody comes on my house I have water
I know don't have nothing for you I have
water everybody knows that my
refrigerator is bare my refrigerator
looks like I am struggling in life like
my refrigerator looks crazy
and I was thinking like okay do I buy a
book because here's where I know I want
a recipe book or two watches go with
what I'm like have a taste for it and
then just google it but here's why this
is what's on my mind so in that same
movie maybe I have to get like Italian
cooking or something but maybe that
because um what's the other actress
Julie okay who have this yeah Amy Adams
she made this like bruschetta okay and
she was just like frying a bread and
olive oil in a pan and then she like put
all like the marinated tomatoes I mean
it's like it I was just like and then
whoever is her love and just I forget
his name he was on
the project okay if you need somebody to
seem like they're from New York he's
like he's dead acting he was eating he
was going to town on it I want I want
that right now right now with that in my
mouth and so it's not today if not today
tomorrow I'm totally making it I'm
rooting for you I think you can do it
cuz you basically just said out loud the
whole recipe from what I can gather
about foreshadow we shut it restaurants
it'll look like that also those are paid
actors to make it seem good no no he was
perfect
well I hope you keep us all up-to-date
throughout the year on your Instagram on
your stories whatever might be on your
cooking misadventures adventures okay
here's a really fascinating question
what stand-ups in your circle do you
think people are sleeping on right now
in my circle or that you just genuinely
really love that you think people should
know about one of my absolute favorite
peers right now is Amir K okay
you know that is no he just knows how to
make something out of nothing in every
single time he has material it has great
material he has some of his jokes are
like oh haha haven't seen his joke in
five I can't wait to see the show yeah
but he also like we've been in
situations where everybody's bombing and
it's like this is definitely the crowd
yeah you know and then a mere comes on
and it's like any and he just you know
I'm you're okay Amir K okay yeah who
else this is so hot I got no offense I
hate questions like this
and it just it just it's like yeah I
know but for some reason I can't tell
your friends I get it that you're like I
uh I was gonna ask you who's the
funniest non comedian in your life but
it sounds like it's your brother it's
actually my mother oh really oh it's
okay so here's just a quick story go for
it
we go to sikri to my before this yes
this is Thanksgiving yeah this has to be
Thanksgiving yeah so I'm like you want
me to see I'm thinking about seeing Cree
- you want me to wait until I get to
Michigan she's like yeah wait for me
wait for me so we go to the movies and
we're talking like through the previews
and in a movie starts and my mom is
still talking I was like over now what
no wait a second like I plan on doing
and she was like well I'm yeah I'm here
with you I was like yeah but the movie
started so what we're not gonna do is
talk and she was like okay well I'll try
and I'm like you'll try so then I sorry
anybody listening that hasn't seen Cree
- spoiler alert at one point have you
not seen I've seen it I cried on a plane
to it yeah I was emotional - it's pretty
great so at the point where Creed is
down mm-hmm right and you kind of like
my mom stands up in the movie - she
stands up in the movie theatre and says
to everyone else watching the movie just
in case we didn't know she said it's
called Creed - it's called Cree it's
called Creed then she starts talking to
Michael B Jordan via the film she was
like baby get up get up get up get up
Michael B Jordan gets up and she claps
and she sits down she says it's Paul
Creed that's how amazing an immersive
the film is that your mom honestly
thought she was in the crowd at that
actual boxing she sounds like the
greatest angel sent from heaven I wish I
was in that movie theater
oh my god okay on that now we're gonna
take one more quick break and then we're
gonna get into some Twitter questions
the internet wants to know a lot of
wonderful things I saw
[Music]
too deep this episode run too deep is
brought to you by the OkCupid dating app
it's the only dating app that finds you
someone based on who you are and what
you're into the OkCupid dating app asks
you fun and meaningful questions that
matter to you so you can be seen by the
people who are going to be into you from
questions like who would pay an extra
five dollars for guac or are you close
to your family and did you vote in the
last election you'll see tons of answers
that lead to great conversations and
great dates with people who feel the
same way you do or maybe not and it's a
helpful way to sift through the fat so
on and so forth
tell people about your favorite album
get your last great trip on record or
your favorite podcasts hint wink wink no
it's not and let them let the love roll
in on the OkCupid app whether you're
looking for that person to join you on a
long walk on the beach cliche but get it
or a short walk to the pool bar more my
speed they're waiting for you on the
OkCupid dating app so start your new
year by meeting someone who's into you
and what you're into on the OkCupid
dating app download the free OkCupid
dating app and find your next great date
to day this episode is brought to you by
one of my favorites me andis Valentine's
Day is right around the corner rather
than spending all that money on going
out to fancy restaurants why not just
hang in your underwear courtesy of me
undies that sounds kind of pervy but
also very comfortable made from the
coveted micro mobile modal micro modal
sorry and so ill-informed on fabrics the
micro modal fabric which is three times
softer than cotton get it micro modal
Mian DS genuinely feels like heaven
against your skin take that in one more
time it feels like heaven against your
skin men and women can each choose from
four different cuts all of which are
available in classic colors and
adventurous prints Oh guys get ready
including new video prints which are
released every Tuesday but why stop
there this year me on DS
launching their v-day prints in lounge
pants and onesies as well you heard me
onesies both are made from the same get
ready micro modal fabric as their undies
I have been sent products from this
company and I can attest to the comfort
level in which I have experienced well
you know riding my dirty skin on their
fabrics the micro modal is choice so
Mandy says a great offer for us our
beautiful listeners first-time
purchasers get 15% off and free shipping
when you order me undies it's a
no-brainer get 15% off a pair of the
most comfortable and easy we'll ever put
on free shipping and 100% satisfaction
guarantee when you go to me undies calm
slash grace that's me undies comm slash
grace okay we're gonna get into some
Twitter question before we do it
wouldn't ask you the two questions asked
every single guess that's on the podcast
and the first is who alive or dead would
you most want to throw a cold spaghetti
act alive we're dead I would want to
throw cold spaghetti a yeah it's a very
intense question we can come back to if
you I think okay the second question is
to tell us your worst pants [ __ ]
story or close call but you can only use
three words or three small phrases so
mine is college jogging front lawn for
5:00 traffic [ __ ] it I love that you
immediately have a story because there's
so many times that people don't have
stories and I stopped relating to them
without the spaghetti one tripped you up
but a pastor the one without hesitation
was answered immediately and I couldn't
appreciate you more for that thank you
I also peed on myself twice in 2018
neither one of those times was I drunk
or had a drink at all and I would like
to change that in 2019
cooking and not being yourself
yeah well speaking of embarrassing
things
someone's to know what's the most
embarrassing thing that's ever happened
to you on stage hmm
the most embarrassing thing that's
happened to me on stage or I kind of
expand this to like a heckler or like
even even like before after being on
stage or anything like that I remember
once I I went off on a rant and or like
you know just started improvising and I
said something about like you know like
if there's a guy in a wheelchair and did
it and of course there was a guy in a
wheelchair
and so the crowd is like laughing but
they I see this like group of people
like and then when I got offstage they
were like you know he's gonna win and I
asked I was like did I offend you he's
like no you were hilarious Mel's like
there's always my fear to be saying some
[ __ ] and then nicely even care enough
think I was making fun of obviously
people in wheelchairs but it had
something to do with dating you know
like what we look for something like
that and it's just even if I said I want
to be in a will [ __ ] you know just that
ignites the crowd awkward also one time
the first time I really bombed it was at
the Comedy Store and you know it's like
my it was the first time I was doing
like a ten-minute set like a full set
yeah and I was like well they've been
seeing me duties like five minutes and
forever I need to do some new material
and I try just like 10 minutes set and
it's like my friends came like everybody
it was like a supposed to be like a
glowing moment for me and I bombed and
everybody was like but the worst part
about it was you know the host is
normally like right next to the stage to
come get you off it's like when I was
like all right guys good night the host
was nowhere to be heard so I was like so
what do you do Chris
where's the house have you ever had
counter to that like an extreme fangirl
moment of being on a show with someone
or seeing someone at a show or just even
being like at a party or social setting
with someone in LA that you're like I
embarrassed myself in front of this
person or I might embarrass myself in
front of this person one show I didn't
tell Washington with an audience it was
a small venue it was a small venue so he
wasn't far away but I saw him as soon as
I walked in and I said oh my god st.
help lead you through your material do
not just do your [ __ ] don't say [ __ ]
don't try it because it's like I didn't
want to like you know have one of those
like 40 and slips I was like just just
say the words to your joke please and I
got through it and like if I'm on stage
right now I was like there was this one
girl right in the front who was just not
like everybody was laughing and she just
was not like oh god and so I was
thinking like I don't know if Denzel can
see you [ __ ] but laughs like what do
you do what are you doing
maybe I was to me after was like you
were great you know yeah touch my arm
and everything yeah yeah it looks like
you were really talented in my mind I
was like what else then I told my mom
she was like did you tell him you have a
mother I was like no absolutely not no
like no that's amazing how long ago was
that maybe I'd say four years ago maybe
oh maybe four years I still had a shaved
head so yeah it had to be at least three
years ago okay yeah that's so nuts but
also congrats great job I did a few of
those moments yeah yeah I've had a few I
mean it must be kind of strange when you
walk out and there's just like an a-list
celebrity in the audience like a regular
person
no if you go anywhere in the world right
now where
where would it be and who would you take
with you I would go to maybe like Egypt
see the pyramids yeah I'd really like to
do that and this is so cliche I would
probably take my mom that's great oh
okay you know like my ex-boyfriend yeah
like my mom would love to experience it
and my mom is like she's down for
whatever she can do it you know she she
can I just know she can she can hang
yeah I'm saying
and then my exploit this particular
ex-boyfriend he's just he's cool like
he's we get along enough that I think
that we would enjoy that experience
together we'd be good travel buddies but
like an occasional argument will break
out and it would be like nothing better
than it would be like okay what's your
connecting city I'll just I'll just wait
for you I'll sleep in this Airport in
Morocco someone to know who is your
biggest stand-up inspiration
I'd say Eddie Murphy was oh yeah yeah
and I'd say like a couple of people like
Eddie Murphy I definitely say Wanda
Sykes I definitely say like now I'm
getting into Richard Pryor he doesn't
inspire me though but he does provide
he motivates me it doesn't inspire me is
that possible
yeah absolutely I think that's the most
articulate way you can describe that
kind of feeling here like I'm not
inspired but I am totally like ready to
continue to work after hearing this
person yeah yeah and like hopefully my
work will be like this work yeah like or
just yet taken into consideration in the
highest regard the way at his time that
was you and they're like perceived by
people yeah and Eddie Murphy was the
first stand-up I ever saw raw was the
first thing about persona although I
didn't have the thought like oh I'm
gonna do comedy it just made me realize
oh I like being made to let I like being
made I like laughing in this way yeah
yeah I like this feeling yeah yeah and
then Wanda just in my career she is like
um she's just a troupe like she's a
supporter yeah hurry and her business
partner they just really supportive and
they give me great advice and like you
know like I remember I was afraid to
like grow my hair back when I was
thinking about it I was like people know
me with the shaved head now I don't want
them to not write like I don't want to I
don't want it to like afterward yeah
exactly and then I remember forget Wanda
said as long as what you you're what you
say is impactful as long as what's
coming out your mouth is you know yeah
it doesn't matter what you look like
she's like because your look
I mean you plan on getting old right you
plan on it was like it was like common
sense you know man it takes a person
with experience to sort of tell you hung
up on the wrong things yeah
yeah and that's also if they're that
inspiring to hear someone that's just
been so in this world for so long still
take care and their actual like
attention to people that are yeah coming
up and doing their thing that's like
very cool to hear and then I'm inspired
by like my peers yeah like I just to
watch us all like constantly and some
people get success and then you see
people who they still do it and it's
like it's not providing them the
response that they're hoping and you
still do it it's like it's really
inspired like yeah alright I'm gonna go
again cuz you just went and so I could I
could do that yeah that's very sweet
okay counter to this someone's know
what's the worst weirdest pick-up line
ever used or heard do you get people
using actual pickup lines on you yeah
you know what I haven't had that in a
while but recently I was just in New
York what like two weeks ago and a
friend of a friend
this guy he's walk like weird a part of
this birthday group cuz we're
celebrating my friends were sure and he
comes up but I don't know anybody except
her okay but that's fine like we're
walking to a place so I'm not trying to
be really chatty yet right it's cold
it's the winter time in here and he
comes up to me and he was like um you
seem like you don't know anybody so I'm
gonna I'm gonna be your friend today and
he and right after he says that he pulls
this blunt that he has and he this is a
I said okay well can you bring my friend
after you smoke that blood thank you
he goes away and smokes and then he
comes back and he's he would you know
what it was it wasn't so much what he
said he thought he was much more
charming than then we sit down at this
restaurant and it's like a big group of
us and I first were like sitting next to
each other and as soon as he turns his
back I switch seats with another girl he
turned back around he was like what
happened I was like
that sounds kind of miserable okay no it
was great okay yeah it was great I'm and
I'm so happy I didn't have to converse
with it and not even like I have no idea
if he's a nice or not nice person it was
just like and also - you're not really
saying what you want see you like me
yeah yeah yeah and you ain't saying you
like me trying to make it seem like I
need like you you like me just say you
like me I have to deal with that man I'm
saying way easier to process now than
playing this game with me yeah do you
get people come here you like but do you
get people coming up to you after shows
ever and that like can you understand
the vibe of like people coming up to you
that are clearly interested you yeah all
the time but no literally yeah oh my god
how do you handle that I mean I just say
thank you and then keep it pushing yeah
yeah you know they might be like oh are
you are you really sing Gori eight even
happens when I'm onstage like I may go
up seek I mean like ask somebody in the
audience you know like oh what do you
look for in a girl and they're gonna say
tall [ __ ] they're gonna describe redjac
they're gonna describe exactly what I
look like and in that moment and then
I'll just make fun of them cuz it's a
comedy show uh-huh and then sometimes
they'll seriously ask me out after the
show and that's fine - it's like shoot
your shot yeah especially if you got it
like this guy in DC I unlike the other
guy I couldn't be mad cuz this is recent
yeah I couldn't be man he said listen
all I could do is tell you did I like
you and asked you that's all I could do
and this is exactly a saying he was so
much taller than me he was like that's
all I could do and I was just like
you're absolutely right that is all you
can do you know yeah he's like so can I
get your number I was like no but
I mean honesty works two ways I was like
you can find me on Instagram he was like
I haven't I haven't been on Instagram is
so long I was like well how bad do you
want to get in contact with oh yeah he
said okay I got a DM from him on
Instagram that's amazing
okay Xena we're at the end of the
podcast what's going on for you this
year what can an everyone look for I
hopefully have a Netflix show coming out
a non-scripted science like social
science show yes we shall we wrapped it
at the end of last year and hopefully
it'll be released this year amazing yes
I'm shooting a half-hour comedy for
Amazon that's so cool when hearing we
shoot in Vancouver starting and we shoot
from like the end of February to like
make ma but I really loved the project I
think it's like I think it's written
very it's smartly written and it's
extremely hilarious to me that's great
and so I'm excited about and I've never
been a series regular show yeah that's
exciting
yeah and what else
well you have your own podcast I have my
own podcast at school honesty with Z
honesty h o NE ste a okay with z which
means is some of it is factual I'm doing
shelves all over okay well yeah fine you
on the road do you have a website that
they can yeah absolutely Zeynep Johnson
is my website zai Na be Johnson in every
social media platform you can find me as
a nap Johnson you've done it correctly
so many people do not create the same
it's just social media across the board
and Congrats I just wanted to be Zeynep
but there's so many thing else in the
world I've so many say naps in the bags
yeah so I had to use Johnson super fun
thank you again for coming off of a
Cancun trip and making time for us yeah
this is awesome make sure you guys will
go check out anywhere across the United
States and internationally and that
you're touring and
oh wait I forgot everyone that's on the
podcast cookie come into frame
everyone gets a personalized fortune
cookie for being a guest on the podcast
so you don't have to eat it but you're
welcome to open some personalized
meaning somebody put this fortune in
specifically for me like this fortune
should say zainab okay but drop that
skincare routine please the people are
asking and they deserve to know how you
achieve that glow so this will be the
last time I bring her up to my mom she
continues to grow in her mystery thank
you so much for making time we'll see
you guys next time another episode of
not too deep good bye too deep toady
toady not too deep who's grace Helbig